Narrator: For over a decade,
"Shark Tank" has been at
the forefront of innovation...
Ruffkess:
BoxLock's a smart padlock.
You put it on a storage
container outside of your house.
The Bear Bowl,
the cook pot that folds flat.
♪ Ahhh ♪
Narrator:
...showcasing America's
most ingenious products
and trendsetting ideas.
‐There you go. [Chuckles]
‐Whoo!
Narrator: And tonight,
branding expert Rohan Oza
returns to the Tank.
My brands get
into more Americans' hands
than anybody else
on the panel.
Just when you think
you've seen it all...
Whoa!
...there's always something new
coming in the Tank.
Oh, wow!
Which of these companies
will be the next big idea?
Touché!
The future starts now.
♪♪
First in the Tank
is a modern version
of a traditional
service business.
♪♪
[ Swedish accent ]
Hi, Sharks. My name is Marc.
Hi. My name is Mikael.
We started
a knife‐sharpening service
by mail.
Knife Aid.
A super‐simple idea
disrupting an old trade
by e‐comm.
For the right Shark,
we're offering the opportunity
to invest $400,000
for 15% of our company.
Ooh,
that's a lot of knives.
A knife is something
most Americans touch every day,
yet knife‐sharpening,
a beautiful, ancient craft,
has almost been lost
and has not been digitalized.
Pretty much everyone
has dull knives at home.
People love
using a sharp knife,
but very few people know how,
where we even have the time
to get those knives
sharpened.
And that's the very reason
we started Knife Aid.
So, this is
how simply it works.
Order online,
receive our secure
postage‐paid envelope
that guarantees
safe shipping.
Take your dull knives
into the envelope,
back in the mailbox,
and off it goes.
And our expert knifesmiths
will work their magic.
They will re‐create
that razor‐sharp edge,
and your knives
will come back to you
sharper than the day
you bought them,
all within about a week.
So, Sharks, who wants
a slice of our business?
[ Laughter ]
O'Leary:
I'm very intrigued.
You may not know this,
but I'm actually Chef Wonderful.
Well, I have blades
made by Japanese artists
that once made
samurai swords.
My most expensive
is now $3,500.
Kevin, you have more junk
in your house
than any human being.
I actually sharpen it
with a stone
that has two different
densities on it.
But we'll take
your samples.
So, out with the samples,
and I think, you know,
we want to have
a little bit of fun
before we start talking
about the business
and really showing
the motion of using it.
I'll try it.
Who is most handy
with a hunting knife?
Like, outdoor.
I'll do outdoor.
Fine.
Soderlindh: What we wanted
to illustrate here is,
everybody knows
how it is cutting
when you have
a super‐sharp knife
and how easy it goes.
Don't do this at home.
Kevin, if you would start
with a dull knife.
I want you to cut through
the pineapple.
Got it.
Right through the center?
Yeah.
And this is a dull knife.
It's very hard to do
with a dull knife.
And, you see, it's not very fun.
So, you're done.
That's the dull knife.
[ Laughter ]
You're done!
Okay, so, now we try
the sharp knife.
You need to hold
the pineapple steady...
‐You want me to swipe at it?
‐Yeah, yeah. Do it.
‐Oh!
‐Look at that!
‐Big difference.
‐Touché!
Rohan, take the rope
and you fold it in two,
and you take
the dull knife first.
Which is the dull one?
The one that doesn't
say "sharp" on it.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughing ]
Sorry about that.
He got joked!
I deserved that one.
Hold it a little bit closer
to the rope there
so it doesn't slip you.
And hemp is super‐hard to cut
in any case.
Now...
Should I go
with the sharp?
Yes, yes.
Oh, I see.
‐Wow.
‐Wow!
Okay.
I detect the accents.
Soderlindh: Alright,
let's start there.
Marc and I moved to the U. S.
to start up this business.
We have a past of building
global brands and businesses.
Where did you
move here from?
We're from Sweden,
but I'm originally from America.
I grew up in Sweden
and moved to America.
Okay, and what was your best
product that you sold before?
I founded Happy Socks.
‐Happy Socks?
‐Oh, I love those.
‐That was you?
‐Yeah, yeah.
Are you still involved
with Happy Socks?
Yes, I am, but I'm not
operational anymore.
I'm on the board
and own them.
And how did you come up
with the knife idea itself?
We saw something
back in our country
that was similar,
but more towards
the commercial side,
and we were thinking about, why
isn't this done for a consumer
and simplify it?
Get an envelope,
get the knives in, fixed price.
It's a quick turnaround.
And how much do you charge?
So, go. Walk us through ‐‐
We would sharpen
an average of $10 a knife
for everything included ‐‐
minimum package,
four knives.
Does it matter the size?
Like, there's serrated,
there's the bread knife,
you know?
Lickfett: Well,
that's what we simplified.
The traditional knife shop
is in a farmers market.
They'll go by inch
and they charge different ‐‐
We made it very simple.
It's per blade.
Doesn't matter the size.
Paring knife
to large knife.
Exactly. And even scissors,
so kitchen scissors,
scissors goes in there,
hunting knives...
Oh, you do scissors, too?
Guys,
I'm a little confused.
Something's bugging me.
Okay.
You, Mikael, are clearly
a successful entrepreneur,
so you've obviously made
a fair bit of money.
Why are you here
seeking money
if you've got a sort of pretty
big stackful already?
I have previously failed
on the U. S. market.
We had another brand
going into the American market
without having American people
involved in the business,
having the funds, raising,
and how you actually drive
growth on the American market.
I'm not gonna
do that mistake again.
We put out
two strategies.
Either we go
to venture capital
and get venture‐capital‐funded
deal on it
or we go all‐American
and what we have seen as
the full‐on American show,
how you reach out and...
The power of the Tank.
What part of this market
do you need to understand?
It's messaging, almost.
It's really
packaging the product,
how to communicate it,
its channel strategy ‐‐
Connecting with a target
core audience, okay.
Exactly.
What are your sales?
So, we're on 120
on this side of the year.
‐$120,000?
‐Yeah.
How'd you get those sales?
So, really, what we've done
is mainly experimentation.
We're now on the fourth
iteration of our website.
So, it's sort of
a proof‐of‐concept sale.
Do you use Instagram ads?
We use Facebook,
Instagram, Google.
How much did you do
last month?
$37,000.
‐$37,000?
‐Yes.
Greiner: Alright, listen,
I'm gonna give you an offer.
I like the concept.
You're fresh, you're unique,
you're different.
You've already
got the packaging down.
It's really quite good.
I think you are smart
in needing to know
what the market is here.
There's nobody who knows better,
I feel, than ‐‐
I think I do know somebody
who knows better.
No, there isn't anybody
that knows better.
Yeah, there is.
I know 'cause I've sold
over a thousand products...
She believes that,
so listen.
...over 20 years
to predominantly U. S. market.
You gonna make an offer?
But it's a risky offer,
okay?
I mean, I have no idea
how this is gonna go.
I'm just gonna give you
a flyer.
You can take it
or leave it.
I'm gonna give you
$200,000 in cash,
I'm gonna give you $200,000
as a line of credit,
and I want 20%.
I mean, if you want someone
to just give you cash, great.
But if you want someone
to give you their mind,
their heart, their soul,
and the grinding it out,
that's me.
‐Well, before we ‐‐
‐Yes?
Channel strategy,
that's obviously something ‐‐
Yes, let's talk
a little bit about it.
That's important to you.
You know,
I think the digital strategy ‐‐
obviously, we know what
we're doing and how to acquire.
‐So you've got that side down.
‐We're down.
But there's still tweaking
to be done.
Of course.
I believe
that there's a lot to do
with physical retail.
What do you mean
"physical retail"?
What do you mean "retail"?
We could put this out
to retailers.
You want them to sell
the service and you just share.
So, in Williams‐Sonoma,
they put up a sign,
they say "Have your knives
sharpened by Knife Aid,"
you pay Williams‐Sonoma,
you know, 25% of it...
Exactly.
...and you try to get
every retailer,
not just Williams‐Sonoma.
And that is brand‐building
because they need
to give us their e‐mail,
and then
we catch them again.
That's easy money, too.
‐So, that's the second channel?
‐Yes.
I could just be like,
"Pick a contact, any contact."
I have it into every
single one of these retailers.
We know that.
That's why we're here.
And you asked us
why we're here.
‐Yep.
‐That's why we are here.
I'm gonna make you
an offer, okay?
I have
all the same contacts,
but I have something
she doesn't have.
I'm Chef Wonderful.
Chef Wonderful's huge in cakes,
chocolates, and meat.
Google him.
He's fantastic.
And I love
to brand stuff...
[ Laughs ]
...around the kitchen.
Soderlindh: Mm‐hmm.
I'll get behind this product
'cause I like it a lot.
Here's my offer ‐‐
I'll give you $400,000
for 20%.
I think that's a great idea
because you get Chef Wonderful.
Oza: Guys,
two is always better than one,
so when you get
the queen of retail
and then you put that together
with the king of branding,
I mean,
that's quite the pairing.
We, too, would like
to give you $400,000
for 20% of the company.
You get two Sharks
instead of one self‐appointed
Chef Wonderful.
My brands get into
more Americans' hands
than anybody else
on the panel.
Corcoran:
Wait, wait, wait.
I think you're being
very aggressive
in what you're asking.
But I like greedy people,
okay?
[ Laughter ]
So, Kevin and I,
we're gonna offer you
$500,000 for...
20%.
We're upping the ante.
If they want to compete,
go ahead.
It's kind of like
an auction.
But we're
the right team for you.
There's no question
about it.
Greiner: You know,
here's the thing ‐‐
sometimes,
you can take more money,
but that doesn't mean
that you're getting
what you really need.
You need Chef Wonderful.
That's what you need.
I would know if I could
fulfill that for you.
‐No question.
‐We want to drive fast.
We have the car.
We know how to scale it.
We know what we're doing,
and we need somebody
to say,
"Take that route.
It's faster.
Take that route.
It's faster."
‐We've done it!
‐That's what I do.
Greiner: What do I always say?
What are my words?
Yeah, we all want
to build something.
Do you guys want to make this
a DTC business?
This is an equity model.
You're gonna have to
raise more cash.
Getting us on board
means that
the biggest venture capitalists
in Silicon Valley
are gonna pay
ungodly evaluations.
Oh, please.
You call up anybody.
They all see you.
And we're gonna take this
to that promised land.
The biggest
venture capitalists?
You call them up,
they're all gonna charge you.
Greiner:
You keep looking over at Mark,
so I have a question.
Soderlindh: Uh‐huh.
Are you waiting for Mark
to give you an offer?
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in.
Lori and Rohan
have offered Marc and Mikael
$400,000 for 20% of their
knife‐sharpening business,
Knife Aid.
Kevin and Barbara
are offering $500,000 ‐‐
also for a 20% stake.
Getting us on board
means that
the biggest venture capitalists
in Silicon Valley
are gonna pay
ungodly evaluations.
Oh, please.
You call up anybody.
They all see you.
Greiner:
You keep looking over at Mark.
Are you waiting for Mark
to give you an offer?
No, I just feel
a lot of energy
coming from
that side of the room.
I'm like, "I don't know
what's going on over there."
Are you gonna
make them an offer?
You asked about
accelerant.
What do you perceive to be
the accelerant that you need?
We just want
more potent outreach.
We need better messaging,
even clearer messaging.
So, there's different ways
to do that, right?
You can buy it,
and that's your SEO, right?
And then there's PR.
‐Exactly.
‐Right.
That's why I'm asking
the question, because ‐‐
Social PR ‐‐
I mean, all those
free traffic sources ‐‐
those, we really
want to boost.
And that's where I think
I'm stronger than the others
because I can walk into
any media outlet
and pick it up,
deal with whoever I want online.
But I'll let you guys
make a decision here
to see if these deals
are what you want or not,
and I'll just wait.
♪♪
Who would say "I really
feel passionate about"?
I'm passionate.
I jumped in first.
Has anybody else spent
4,000 bucks on a knife?
Mikael, you asked,
"Who's passionate?"
This is real.
I know how to scale.
No, but passionate,
because you have a lot
of businesses.
You're involved in a lot.
So we need to know
that the person
that steps on board with us
is actually gonna give us
one hour more
than the other brand
you stepped onto.
O'Leary: Mikael, ask any ‐‐
‐That's important to us.
‐Mikael, who else ‐‐
My entrepreneurs call me
at 4:00 in the morning.
Smart. Smart question.
Mikael, who has spent
$4,000 on a blade?
Moi. Nobody else.
Oza: That's not
your target market.
You got to make a call
here, Mikael.
We're making a call.
Just have a quick chat.
‐Yeah.
‐You have 30 seconds.
Damn,
you guys grovel enough?
Well, why don't you
make an offer?
[ Laughs ]
‐Yeah, that's a good deal.
‐I don't beg or grovel.
I'm a [bleep] Shark.
I am not above
doing whatever it takes.
Absolutely.
I'm with you, Lori.
You tell them, Lori.
♪♪
Oza: They're taking too long.
We got to get them back.
Excuse me.
♪♪
I thought this was against
the rules, you know?
No, there's no rules.
Greiner: You know,
excuse me, guys.
You want to know
about passion, right?
Well, I'm not sitting,
waiting.
I want this deal.
Yeah.
I'm here.
I'm with you.
Okay, so, for us,
we would really want you
to move up
to $500,000 for 20%
because it would feel better
for us walking out of here
knowing that we got the same
as the other guys.
Why not?
[ Laughs ]
I can't even hear
what's going on now.
‐And really do everything.
‐Don't make a mistake.
‐Yeah. Can I ‐‐
‐I think at the very least ‐‐
You, go away.
No, no.
What do we need?
Lori, I'll back you!
I love your deal,
and I think Barbara and I
can really
blow this thing up.
Lori, I'm in.
You guys know what
brand‐building is about.
Plus, we're offering you
an extra $100,000.
No.
We came here with a target
of Lori and Rohan,
but I want them
to go up to $500,000
'cause then me and Marc
will walk out of here ‐‐
‐But wait. No, wait.
‐Done.
‐Wait, wait, wait.
Soderlindh: It's closing.
It's closing.
‐Let me ‐‐ Let me ‐‐
‐It closed. Goodbye.
‐It's closed. It's closed.
‐[ Laughs ]
Oza: It's closed.
Let me get you
an extra hundred.
‐Ah!
‐It's closed.
Guys, I could have got you
an extra $100,000.
♪♪
Having four Sharks
running after us
into the hallways
is something
I would never dream of.
And, like, I don't know
what's going on.
The key was
he wanted 100,
and as soon as I said "Done,"
there was no debate.
It's a new breed of Shark
that grovels.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Narrator: In Season 10,
we watched Danh Tran
make a deal
with Robert Herjavec
for his men's shirt brand
Butter Cloth.
Cuban:
Congratulations, Danh.
‐Yeah!
‐[ Laughs ]
Narrator: Let's see
what they're up to now.
Since "Shark Tank,"
I feel like I'm jumping!
It has been seven months.
We've done $3 million in sales
and sold 30,000 shirts.
Danh!
Herjavec:
Butter Cloth has a pop‐up event
in Los Angeles today.
I wouldn't miss it
for the world.
$3 million in sales
in 7 months ‐‐
that's incredible.
I am so proud of Danh.
It's amazing.
I have
my own collection!
Tran: He inspired us to create
Robert Herjavec Collection,
and it's our
best‐selling collection.
Nice to meet you.
I'm Robert.
This is my mom.
This is my dad.
Nice to meet you.
Tran:
I grew up in Vietnam
and worked with my family
in a small tailor shop.
I learned a lot
from my mom and my dad,
especially my mom.
She taught me everything.
She say that you can create
your own destiny.
You can create
anything you want.
I achieved my American dream.
I love the product,
but I love him.
Herjavec: You know,
I saw a kindred spirit in Danh.
We're fellow immigrants.
I know how hard it is.
And this is the great thing
about this country.
Look at Danh.
He started with nothing,
and he's creating
the American dream
for himself, for his family,
and making me proud.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the tank
is a simple solution
for a common annoyance.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Kelley.
And I'm Ellen McAlister.
And we're from beautiful
South Florida.
And our product sucks.
We mean it.
[ Laughs ]
It, like ‐‐
literally, it sucks.
The best way
we can explain this to you
is to introduce you
to one of our customers.
This is
Mosquito Magnet Mom.
Greiner: Oh!
It doesn't matter
where she goes ‐‐
the mosquitos
will bite her.
[ Laughs ]
At least she has some items
around the house
to help her with the itching
and swelling, right?
Wrong.
At this point,
she's desperate
and starts scouring
the Internet
for mommy blogs
and home remedies
that tell her
to do things
like rub dryer sheets
over her bites
or even apply
a hot spoon.
Aah!
[ Laughter ]
But none of these remedies
are working, either.
[ Groans ]
Cuban: [ Laughs ]
None of them
are addressing
what is causing her body
to itch and swell.
Huh?
In this case,
it's the mosquito saliva.
For other insects,
it can be their venom.
But what if I told you
that I have a tool
that can remove
the insect saliva venom
from a bite or sting
so your body stops
producing the reaction
that is causing you
to itch and swell?
I'd tell you, "Get on with it!
I'm dying over here!"
Here. Use this.
Bug Bite Thing.
Oh.
‐Bug Bite Thing.
‐That's neat.
What's it called?
Bug Bite Thing.
Yeah.
What's the name of it?
Bug Bite Thing.
‐Bug Bite Thing.
‐It's very clear.
Higney:
Bug Bite Thing.
How do you use it?
It's easy.
You simply place it
over a bite or sting,
apply a little pressure,
slowly pull up
on the handles,
and hold
for 10 to 30 seconds
while the irritant is drawn
into the removable cap.
Then,
release the suction,
wash out the end cap,
and you're ready
for your next bite.
Aren't you gonna tell them
what we want?
I was getting to that.
Sharks,
we are seeking $150,000
in exchange for 10% equity
in our company.
So, who wants to help us take
the bite out of a sting with...
Bug Bite Thing?
Ellen, you have won
the "Shark Tank" Academy Award.
Yeah. You definitely get Best
Supporting Actress, for sure.
So, take a package
and a loose one, please.
And a loose one?
Okay, got it.
Yeah.
Yeah, I like the name
'cause it's pretty clear.
"Oh, go get that
Bug Bite Thing."
Does this work on ticks?
Higney: So, the product
works on insects
that leave
their saliva or venom
just under the surface
of the skin,
so that's mosquitos, bees,
wasps, red ants ‐‐ venom.
Can we show some
before‐and‐after pictures...
Oza: Sure.
...so you can
kind of see?
Yes.
Maybe that will
help you guys
visualize
a little bit better.
Oza: Oh, here we go.
Greiner: [ Gasps ] Wow.
Okay, so,
this is one ‐‐
This little boy's name's
Colin.
This is an image that
we received from his mom.
As soon as the children
start swelling,
you use the tool,
and it instantly gives you
the relief
because you're expelling
the venom.
How long is
the time period there?
That's after, probably,
within the hour, she told me.
Really?
That's pretty cool.
I love your guys' energy.
Can you give me ‐‐
What's the relationship here?
What's the background?
This is Mom.
[ Chuckles ]
Yeah, that was my assumption,
but I ‐‐ you know?
Yes, this is my mom.
How did you
come up with this?
My husband and I moved from
California to South Florida
about six years ago,
and I was never even close
to being prepared
for the mosquitos
in Florida.
So, when I was working
in our family‐owned company,
we deal with a lot of
overseas customers,
and I had, of course,
had a fresh bite,
and I was complaining,
and I said,
"Gosh, these mosquitos
are killing me out here."
And one of our customers,
she said,
"Have you heard of a tool
that takes out the irritant
so you stop itching
and swelling?"
And I said, "No."
So, we tracked down
the manufacturer of the product.
We actually
teamed up with him.
It seems very replicable,
though.
I mean, there can't be
a patent on this thing
in any capacity.
I mean...
There's not a patent,
but our manufacturer
is in Denmark.
It has clinical trials.
We were able to secure
an exclusive deal with him
for the entire
United States.
Good for you.
Do you have to pay
a royalty on it?
McAlister: No.
We just purchase it
directly from him.
Just buy‐out, that's it.
Yep.
What do you sell these
for, and what does it
cost you to make them?
So, we sell them online
for $9.95.
Okay.
And we're the number‐one
best‐seller
in insect bite relief
on Amazon.
How much
did you sell last year
and what are you
selling this year?
Last year,
we sold $500,000.
‐You've got to be kidding.
‐Good for you.
This year,
in the first five months,
we've sold $800,000.
Yeah, baby!
And we're projected to do
over $2 million
by the end
of September.
Wow.
And your margins
are pretty good on this, no?
We have
an 80% margin online.
So, what does it cost you
to make one of these?
We import them in.
It costs us $1.53 landed.
‐Okay.
‐It's not expensive.
Packing is running
about 40 cents,
so $2.
$2. Okay.
Are you in, like, CVSs,
Walgreens, all of that?
So, this year, we were able
to secure a deal
with a large
pharmacy chain store,
and we're in over 7,000
of their stores this year.
So, let me ask you
a question.
I like your guys' energy.
I like your guys' vibe.
I'm gonna make you
an offer.
I would do the $150,000 for 10%.
Take it.
I mean, I can put this through
the entire retail chain.
I mean, my products are
in every store in America.
Marketing and branding
is kind of my thing.
This would blow out
at Walmart.
We'll get that in
no problem.
You know, this is
the first time in a long time
a valuation comes into
"Shark Tank" that's reasonable.
Well, we understand the value
that you can bring us.
I made an offer, Kevin,
so, you can ‐‐
I'd like to offer you
$200,000 for 10%.
♪♪
Thank you very much.
I can get products out in retail
in a way Barbara can't.
Oh,
that's just not true.
You know,
she doesn't do that.
I mean, my brands are all
over America.
We can all do that ‐‐
everybody here.
I'm gonna give you
the $150,000.
I'm gonna drop the equity ask
down to 6%,
and I want
a buck a unit, too.
That's, like,
triple‐dipping.
Oza: What you're really
looking for here
is who can get you
the best retail access
for the right customers
across America.
Is that correct?
Me. I have products
in every retailer.
Yes,
and we need some funding
because we have to bring
the product in in advance,
in order to have time
to package it and prepare it.
Right, so
it's a cash‐flow scenario.
Cuban: So, you do
the packaging yourself?
We are right now.
So, you need help
with the whole
organizational side of it.
Yes.
Yeah.
First of all, I hate bugs,
I hate mosquitos,
and I hate things that bite
because they bite me.
So...
[ Chuckles ]
I don't do this often.
I'm offering you
my Golden Ticket.
‐Oh, Lord.
‐Oh, my, oh, my.
This is truly gold.
I'm giving you exactly
what you walked in asking for.
She's not paying as much
as I offered you.
I'm giving you
exactly what you asked for.
So, if you want my ticket,
it's right here.
What's the ticket about?
The $150,000 for 10%.
That's what
the Golden Ticket's about.
I will let you write and sign
on the contract
with my magic pen.
Corcoran: Golden Ticket.
I don't get it.
This pen
is incredibly lucky.
There's only one of it
in the world.
‐Tell them about your pen.
‐They have lost their marbles.
Barbara, do you want
to go in together.
Yeah.
It's right here.
Come on. Take it!
Because it might go away.
I hear mumbling,
and when I hear mumbling,
it worries me.
So, you guys,
do you want my offer?
Kevin, you want to go in
on this?
Yeah?
Do you want my offer?
I mean, guys,
you've got Kevin, me...
I'm the best one for you.
You know I am.
Well, you haven't heard
from Mark, either.
You're gonna get two Sharks
for the price of one.
‐We're gonna do a little combo.
‐I wouldn't jump.
Take a deep breath.
‐Uh‐oh.
‐Take a deep breath.
‐Two sharks.
‐Uh‐oh.
You wanted to give
$200,000 for...
Two sharks in one,
ladies.
You guys.
♪♪
Lori, we'd like
to do a deal.
‐Thank you!
‐[ Laughs ]
Whoo! Yes!
You're the right partner.
That's who they wanted.
Oh, it was
the right move!
Thank you so much.
Damn.
Oh,
here's your ticket.
Thank you. Hooray!
Yay!
‐Good luck to you.
‐Congratulations, guys.
Lori, I give you credit.
Cuban: Congrats, Lori.
You took on the whole gang
with your Golden Ticket.
I am so proud of you.
Ah!
Oh, my God.
We just made a deal for Lori
for exactly what we asked.
I know.
I can't even believe
that just happened right now.
Holy moley.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a convenient
and discreet solution
to an embarrassing problem.
[ Laughs ]
‐Oh, wow.
‐Oh.
The entrance
on the throne.
‐Oh, my gosh.
‐[ Laughs ]
"Game of Thrones."
Hello, Sharks.
I'm Tyler Jay,
and I'm seeking $150,000
for a 10% stake in my company,
Plop Star.
Sharks,
I know we just met,
but I want to talk to you
about how you poop.
[ Chuckles ]
Like a lot of people,
if I wasn't in the privacy
of my own home,
I wasn't comfortable
going number two
because of the smell
I might leave behind.
Traditionally bathroom aerosols
just mask the stench,
leaving a sticky film behind
and a bathroom that smells...
[ Sniffs ]
...like a stinky rose garden.
And all these new
drops and sprays
used before going number two
are cumbersome,
leak in a purse,
in a pant pocket.
So, I invented ‐‐
wait for it...
[ Exhales sharply ]
Plop Star,
the world's most discreet
and portable
toilet odor eliminator.
Each Plop Star tablet
is individually wrapped
for ideal portability.
So, how does
Plop Star work?
Just gently drop one tablet
in the bowl
before your performance,
wait a few seconds
before taking a seat.
Plop Star starts
dissolving instantly,
releasing a buffer
of essential oils
on the surface of the water
that block bathroom odors
before they begin.
So, Sharks, which one of you
wants to partner with us
and start a movement?
So, I mean,
the number of puns in there.
O'Leary: Quick question
on the advanced technology here.
When the excrement
goes below the surface...
Ah, geez.
...the odorous gases
are trapped underneath
the oil‐film surface?
Is that the idea?
That is correct.
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
Can I pass out
some samples real quick?
‐We'd like to see them.
‐Yes, samples, please.
Greiner:
Oh, you're bringing us water.
We can all plop.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, thanks, buddy.
Are there different flavors
or just one plopper?
There's just one plopper
so far.
We just go ahead?
Plop it in?
Yeah, plop it in.
Give it a drop.
Thank you.
‐Thank you, sir.
‐Plop, plop.
‐You're welcome.
‐Like we're in the laboratory.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Let's see what that's ‐‐
Oh, it smells good.
Oza: Yeah, it smells like
a vitamin C tablet.
‐It smells refreshing.
‐Yeah.
Cuban: There are several things
that I know.
One ‐‐ I'm a man who likes
to leave his mark.
[ Laughter ]
Unbelievable.
Oh, no!
Two ‐‐
I'm out with prejudice.
That's the greatest out
I've ever seen.
[ Both laugh ]
This has six packets in it.
What does it sell for?
Alright, so, we have
two units right now.
The six‐pack is called
the Weekender.
We sell that for $4.99.
[ Chuckles ]
And then our 30‐pack
is $12.99.
‐What's the revenue?
‐Well, what are your sales?
Like, right now,
we have $12,000 in sales.
Cuban: Oh!
Your consumer doesn't seem
to be loving this thus far
or doesn't see the need.
No, I think what it is ‐‐
and why I'm here ‐‐
is because I really wanted
to build the back,
the manufacturing,
make sure that we
had all our nuts and bolts
before we kind of
started promoting.
Before you prove demand?
That's the reverse order of
what should happen here.
Because you're asking me
for a $1.5 million valuation ‐‐
$150,000, 10% ‐‐
and all you got
is $12,000 in sales.
I don't know if anybody
really wants Plop Star.
I'll tell you guys a little bit
about my background.
‐Please do.
‐Yeah.
I've worked at
large advertising firms,
and five years ago,
I actually started
my own production company.
I've been
incredibly successful.
I do broadcast spots
for large corporations ‐‐
advertising, PR ‐‐
and also direct
to tech firms.
And I wanted to create
a product ‐‐
something that I could
create the content for
that looks super professional
at a cheap rate.
And I kind of had my "Aha"
moment a couple years ago.
My little daughter,
she loves making bath bombs,
and I was like, "Wow.
This would be the perfect
form factor."
Okay.
That makes sense.
So that was
my big "Aha" moment.
There is an 800‐pound gorilla
in this market.
I guess I'll say ‐‐
It's Poo‐Pourri.
Yeah, of course.
Yeah. And it's
a $300 million brand.
They did $56.5 million.
It's a growing category.
The convenience of not
having to carry a bottle ‐‐
it's innovative.
And listen, Squatty Potty
is my investment.
Correct.
And everybody laughed
at a little stool
that helps you poop.
No, I believe in toilet
in portfolio.
But they have just hit
$160 million in sales,
5 million
Squatty Potties sold.
So, you know,
this could potentially fit
within my family
of entrepreneurs
in the Squatty Potty.
Oza: What you've created here
is interesting.
I think that you've made
the form factor convenient,
and I don't think
that the target audience for you
is B‐to‐C in consumers.
Because when people go
to other bathrooms,
there's a mind‐set
that's absolutely bizarre.
They have no respect.
So you kind of need to target
a business model...
You mean public?
...where that people
who are working in hotels
or public restrooms are like,
"I can drop this
every time."
'Cause it's the guy
before and after me
that destroys the place.
But don't you think
it's a little bit expensive
to sell to businesses?
That's the problem
right there.
Because it is pricy.
I mean,
they like industrial ‐‐
big, huge gallons
of things
and, you know,
the cheap‐as‐can‐be
because they're just
pouring it down a toilet
and they don't care.
Yes.
The B‐to‐B model,
I don't believe is gonna work.
Not for a second.
But here's what we see
again and again on "Shark Tank,"
which always disturbs me,
is your approach to business,
right?
I see you as a cautious,
respectful, intellectual guy,
very bright,
assessing, analyzing,
figuring out
how you're gonna do it.
You get it right, you're gonna
get all the pieces in place.
But you forgot
to take it out to market
and see if there's
even a demand there.
I don't believe there's
a demand for this product,
so I'm out.
Okay.
You should flush it down
the friggin' toilet.
I'm not kidding.
This is going nowhere.
Greiner: Oh, Kevin.
This is gonna be a zero.
Plop Star sucks.
I'm out.
It's a bad idea.
Tyler, Tyler, listen.
There's a lot of competition
in this area,
so I just don't feel
it's investable for me,
so I'm out.
Jay: You're out?
Well,
can I just tell you ‐‐
I have a 10‐ and 8‐year‐old,
and I love them.
I've been working
relentlessly after hours
to make this work.
And, like, my son,
he just goes,
"Dad, this is so cool that
you're building something
that's physically tangible
and bringing it to market."
I actually quite like your idea,
by the way.
O'Leary: Whoa.
What you've created here
is interesting,
but where I struggle is,
you don't have
a game plan.
I feel if I give you
that $150,000...
Can I tell you
what I'd do with it?
...you're gonna flush it.
Because there's no plan
behind it.
I do have a plan,
and it's B‐to‐B.
It's the omnichannel,
making sure if we could
get into retail ‐‐
You see,
but that's not a plan.
No, no, no,
I was saying that ‐‐
Right there.
I love your energy, but you
said, "I want to go B‐to‐B."
Great. And then, "Oh,
and omnichannel and retail."
So, with the B‐‐
It's too many "ands."
I'm sorry, but I'm out.
Alright.
Plop Star ‐‐
it's over.
Alright.
Guys, thank you so very much.
‐Good luck.
‐Take care.
‐Bye, Tyler.
‐Thank you.
Tyler,
do the right thing.
You're riding
back out on that?
You guys, have a good one.
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
Congrats, Tyler.
Good luck.
His coming in and going out
was the best part.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Jay: I think the Sharks
made a big mistake
by not investing in Plop Star.
I think you're gonna see us
everywhere,
and I really do want to prove
all of them wrong
and go, "Man, I should have
gone in on with them."
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a healthier version
of a guilty pleasure.
♪♪
What's going on, Sharks?
My name is Samy Kobrosly,
hailing from
Rockville, Maryland.
♪♪
What's going on, Sharks?
I know. There's a lot going on.
What's going on, guys?
I'm hailing from
Rockville, Maryland,
and it may not
look like this to you,
but I'm a Muslim, okay?
And part of being a Muslim
means no pork whatsoever.
And my friends
would always talk about
how delicious a pork rind
or a chicharrón were,
and I decided,
"You know what?
I'm gonna make myself
one of them pork rinds
or one of them cracklins,
but without the meat."
And a few months later,
the Snacklin was born.
They're made
with real ingredients
that a 6‐year‐old
can pronounce.
Mushrooms...
Oza: Okay.
...onions...
and yuca.
‐Yuca.
‐Yum.
Now, Sharks, I don't know
if you're ready for it yet,
but they're not just
delicious chips.
They're 80 calories
for the whole bag.
Wow.
Not some stupid
serving size.
The whole bag
is 80 calories,
so you can finally
eat the whole bag of chips.
Mm, mm, mm!
[ Laughter ]
Just like that.
Now, I'm here today
because as we expand,
those big boys ‐‐
they're gunning for us,
and I'll need a Shark on my side
as I take them on
in a little bit of
a snack‐to‐mouth combat.
[ Laughter ]
Now, Sharks,
who's ready to eat
the whole bag with me?
‐Let's go.
‐Let's try some.
‐Let's try it.
‐Let's do this.
Love the 80 calories.
Yeah.
So, here you go.
Lovely. Thank you, Samy.
Yep. Absolutely.
Greiner: Yum.
Oza: Any particular order
or just go for it?
You can go for it.
They're all gonna be delicious.
O'Leary: Thank you.
Can't wait to get all the crumbs
on my suit.
‐Thank you very much.
‐Absolutely.
And last, but not least.
Thanks, Samy.
Can I see the bags, too, Samy?
Yep. Absolutely.
Thank you, sir.
So, I'm here today
seeking $250,000
for 2.5% of my company,
Snacklins.
‐Hello!
‐What?!
‐Hoo‐whoo!
‐You cheapskate.
‐iAy, papi!
[ Laughs ]
‐This should be fun.
‐Wow.
So, you're gonna have
Chesapeake Bay flavored
barbecue, miso ginger.
Like I said, they're gonna be
crunchy, they're gonna be salty,
you're gonna get that nice
umami bomb from the mushrooms.
I like the lightness.
It makes me feel like
I'm eating something healthy.
I must say ‐‐ the first bite
tasted like paper.
Now I've had my fourth.
I'm starting to dig it.
That's some good paper,
though, right?
And you know what I'm
really liking about it?
I'm only eating 80 calories
for the whole bag.
I know.
That's what I like.
This was my chance to really
make my impact, you know?
I love junk food.
Everyone likes junk food.
But the problem is, it's junk.
No one else has figured out
how to use fresh ingredients ‐‐
not some weird,
powdered form of it ‐‐
fresh ingredients to make
a shelf‐stable chip
that tastes like junk food.
And that "Aha" moment came
because we knew that
we had something special.
Samy, who's "we"?
I say "we" 'cause we're
a big family at Snacklins.
So, everyone
from our first employees
who are still with us today,
angel investors,
friends and family ‐‐
you know, everyone has
a piece of the company, so...
So, how much of the company
do you have?
I personally own 30%.
How much
do the employees own?
The employees
have a 10% pool.
Good for you.
That's awesome.
Thank you.
This is probably the sportiest
valuation I've seen in a while.
$10 million.
$10 million valuation,
correct?
I hope you have some sales,
Samy.
I think
you'll appreciate this.
Last year,
we sold $200,000 in product,
and this year, we'll finish
the year at around $2 million.
What?!
We've grown tenfold
in the past year,
selling to about
850 stores nationwide.
Wow.
We started off
with 36 stores
about a year and a half ago.
From mom‐and‐pops
to national chains,
such as Whole Foods,
Walmart, 7‐Eleven.
We went out there,
we hit the pavement ourselves.
I mean, I can tell you, when I
had that meeting with 7‐Eleven,
my baby was born
the night beforehand.
And so, four hours later,
I jumped on a plane
and I went to Dallas, and I met
with the heads of 7‐Eleven.
Respect the hustle.
I'll do anything
I have to,
because Snacklins
is that important to us.
‐I respect the hustle.
‐Break down the numbers for me.
We're running, currently,
at about 30% gross margin.
We've invested
a lot in ourselves
with, you know,
building our own factory.
We're not using
some co‐packer.
Oh, you built
your own factory?
‐We built our own.
‐Kevin's gonna love this one.
I want to see the same employees
that I had with me ‐‐
‐Why would you do that, Samy?
‐I offered.
'Cause we're building
American jobs,
and I think that creating
American jobs ‐‐
No, but there's
co‐packers in America
that already spent
the money.
But they're not, and that's why
I think Snacklins is so unique.
There's not a single co‐packer
that is doing what we're doing.
I'm entirely for
building your own factory
because I've never seen
a food product succeed
where they didn't take control
of the kitchen.
Mm‐hmm.
It's an essential thing
you have to do,
but that you did it so quickly
shocks me.
How much money
did you raise?
We raised $1.5 million
to date.
‐Wow.
‐Wow. That was quick.
‐That's a lot of trust.
‐It's a lot of trust.
We've had some
pretty great partners throughout
that have helped us
get through there.
Why do you need us?
Because we're about
11 months, 12 months away
from becoming profitable.
I have enough money
to last me about 10 months,
and not only do I think
a strategic Shark
who, A, could help me out
with retailers,
could help me out
with really exploring
the avenues that it is out
there, but that would give us
that last two months
of funding we need
before we become profitable.
So, what do you sell
each bag for?
So, each bag goes for about
$1.99 to $2.29 on the shelf
depending where it's at.
And what's your cost?
Our cost right now
is about 90 cents.
Wow.
So, your margins
aren't awesome,
and that's
part of the problem.
I invested in a phenomenal
business called Pipcorn.
Mm‐hmm.
And if I were
to say to you that today,
they have 3,500 stores
and $12 million in sales,
you would say
"Wow. What a success."
But now I'm gonna give you
the other side of it.
They have
negligible profit.
I haven't made a dime
on that business,
and they've just
finished selling off
about 1/3 of the business
to try to raise
yet more money again
for the slotting fees
to buy the shelf space.
This food space is tough.
But most importantly, it takes
enormous amounts of money.
That's the problem.
You're gonna chip
your way down.
You constantly have to feed
the dragon with more cash.
So, because I've been there
and done that...
Mm‐hmm.
...I'm out.
Alright,
thank you, Barbara.
I love things
in the space
of being 80 calories for
a healthy, lighter snack.
But I feel
it's a little too risky
and too early for me
right now.
Your valuation
doesn't make sense.
‐Oh, I appreciate that.
‐So, I'm sorry. I'm out.
Thank you so much.
‐Samy, look here.
‐Yeah?
I really do like
your ingredients,
and I like the trend
that you're going down.
But where I struggle is,
your valuation's out to lunch,
you own your own manufacturing,
which I hate.
Manufacturing your own stuff
in this industry
is just tough as heck.
And I would 100% agree.
And it is economically
just not viable, long‐term.
So, unfortunately,
I'm out.
Well, thank you.
I think the reason that we are
doing our own manufacturing
is because no one else
has figured out how to do this.
Yeah, look.
They're wrong.
I talk about Alyssa's Cookies
all the time.
You're familiar with them,
right?
Absolutely. Yeah.
So, started ‐‐ the guy was
living out of his car,
had no money, came to me,
and now six years later,
we'll do $20 million in sales.
The better part is, we'll do
$8 or $9 million in profits
that'll be distributed
to me.
Yeah.
And so
we're killing it.
Now, one of the things that
I fought Doug on originally
was his own factory.
Mm‐hmm.
I was wrong,
he was right,
because he was
the only one
who could do the process
that he invented.
So, having
something unique ‐‐
It's yours. Do it.
Now, in terms of this ‐‐
$10 million valuation.
Won't even argue that.
But...one fatal flaw.
♪♪
2.5%, right?
That's $250,000 worth,
right?
Mm‐hmm.
Even if you gave that to me
and said it was free,
it wouldn't be
worth my time.
Well, what would be worth
your time, then, Mr. Cuban?
A whole lot more
than that.
Now, if you want to make me
an offer I can't refuse,
I'll listen,
but otherwise, I'm out.
♪♪
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out.
Mark is interested
in Samy's vegan pork rinds
company, Snacklins,
but he wants a better deal
than the $250,000 for 2.5%
Samy is offering.
If you want to make me an offer
I can't refuse, I'll listen,
but otherwise, I'm out.
♪♪
I think a strategic partner
like you
was kind of why
we set this up for,
and I'd be willing to do ‐‐
you know, I'll double it.
5% for the 2 1/2.
‐[ Whistles ]
‐[ Laughs ]
That's...
I turn down deals like that
every day.
Samy, surely you have room
in your pocket
to make him
a better offer.
Oza: Samy, I'm telling you,
you need him. I've done this.
The only brand, to be fair,
in this space that I've seen
that's making
genuinely high profits
on a relatively small scale
is Alyssa's.
I give him that.
The bulk of the brands
in this industry, though,
you're gonna need
a ton more cash,
so if he can do to yours
what he did to Alyssa's...
So, Samy,
he turned you down at 5%.
Are you willing
to modify that even more?
Yes or no?
Yeah.
We could figure it out.
I'm listening.
Like I said, I'm here.
I'm scrappy.
I'm here to make something work.
I'm here to work hard.
But the problem is, Samy,
you only have 30%,
and I don't want to throw you
under the bus, right?
You have other shareholders
that you have to consider.
I mean,
I want to be fair.
And I think,
with all due respect,
I used to own
100% of nothing,
and I'm living
the American dream.
I mean, I'm a Muslim
first‐generation American
who is now pitching
a vegan pork rind
on "Shark Tank."
[ Laughter ]
Like, if that's not
the American dream,
I don't know what is,
you know?
I like it.
And so, yeah,
I'll work with you, you know?
Come back with something.
If it's cool,
I'd like, you know ‐‐
But you're here now,
so I'll do the $250,000
for 5% straight equity,
5% advisory shares that can vest
over three years.
So it's a little bit easier
on your investors
and your employees.
♪♪
‐Okay.
‐Deal?
I think
that's a great deal.
Oza: That's a deal!
Done.
Congratulations.
Thank you so much.
I'm excited for you.
Well done.
‐Great job, Samy.
‐Good guy.
Kobrosly: I cannot believe
that I just made a deal
with the Mark Cuban.
He can help us get there
and really show
that Snacklins isn't
some bougie, highfalutin snack
that no one can afford.
It's an approachable snack
that anyone can afford.
♪♪